vincent montagne président de média
participations et du syndicat national
de l'édition
bonjour vincent montagne merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors bruno le maire évoque aujourd'hui
la fermeture des rayons produits non
essentiels dans les grandes surfaces
est ce que c'est une annonce qui quelque
part rassure n'est librairie qui elles
doivent fermer leurs portes
en ces temps de confinement moi je pense
que c'est une décision qui est pas qui
n'est pas la bonne décision à prendre
les librairies et à au même titre que
les hypers et les grandes surfaces ont
pris toutes les dispositions qu'il
fallait depuis le mois de mars pourrait
être adapté au co vide
donc je ne vois pas bien l'intérêt de le
faire je pense que il faut oublier c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une pétition signée
aujourd'hui par plus de cent trente cinq
mille personnes pour dire et écouter la
lecture est extrêmement importante
justement quand on est confiné et si le
confinement est stricte et bien il faut
que les gens puissent avoir un exutoire
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
surtout dans ces temps si j'ose dire
d'obscurantistes me qui rajoute du
stress au stress de la maladie elle-même
et bien sûr les libraires sont forcément
touché 1 par cette épidémie de kovy 19
comme comme tous les premiers
commerçants
quel est l'état général aujourd'hui de
la librairie en france l'état général
est plutôt bon et précisément nous
entrons dans une phase novembre et
décembre les ventes les mises en place
de deux nouveaux auteurs ou de bethel
auteurs sont très importantes
c'est vraiment le livre est quelque
chose que l'on 9 à noël et c'est pas en
quinze jours que l'on règlera les ventes
il faut absolument qu'il y ait deux
devant la la profusion littéraire du
temps pour pouvoir être conseillés et
pour pouvoir l'acheter
donc nous nous considérons que il
faudrait ouvrir au plus vite on comprend
qu'il ya peut-être quinze jours devant
nous de sécurisation et de mise en place
de protocoles sanitaires indispensables
mais s'il nous faut absolument réouvrir
mais pas le 20 décembre il faut ouvrir
beaucoup plus tôt que ça si jamais les
librairies réouvre dans les jours à
venir est ce que vous pensez pas que ça
va donner un petit peu la puce à
l'oreille et aux autres commerçants qui
vont se demander pourquoi les librairies
et pas eux
nous nous considérons que le livre est
un produit essentiel s'est pas produit
yeux comme les autres et je pense que
deux d'ailleurs il ya une législation
très très particulière pour le aux
livres ou faisant vous voyez le livre il
ya une espèce de c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit gondole justement comme c'est
presqu'une heure c'est presque un
médicament il ya quelque chose de très
fort parce que il transforme notre notre
façon de voir les choses notre liberté
intérieure mais nous pensons que il faut
considérer le livre comme un produit
essentiel
anne hidalgo la maire de paris annonce
une initiative commune avec d'autres
villes pour autoriser la réouverture des
librairies indépendantes
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle oui c'est
une bonne nouvelle il faut que le
gouvernement lâche un peu de lest aussi
parce que vous pouvez pas rentrer
aujourd'hui il ya des librairies ouverte
vous pouvez aller à droite pour acheter
du papier de la colle et vous pouvez pas
aller à à gauche pour acheter un livre
je pense qu'en termes sanitaires tout
ceci est totalement absurde
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez que
librairies sont suffisamment armé
justement pour pouvoir respecter tous
ces protocoles de sécurité
en ce moment je pense qu'elles sont
d'autres d'autant plus armé que si elles
sont ouvertes les clés les clients qui
viennent ne se précipite pas il ya
beaucoup moins de concentration dans une
librairie en temps ne dort mal quand
elles sont ouvertes que dans un
hypermarché donc les règles sanitaires
sont beaucoup plus faciles à appliquer
dans une librairie merci beaucoup
vincent montagne d'avoir été
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
et je rappelle que vous êtes président
de média participations et du syndicat
national de l'édition merci beaucoup